كان هناك اغلاق للاسواق وحاله امنيه في
غايه الصعوبه
الان الواقع بدا مغايرا
لشيء من يعني مغايرا جدا لان الاسواق فتحت
ابوابها واخذ الناس
يستطيعون بكل سهوله الحصول على
مستلزماتهم
وشراء احتياجاتهم لشهر رمضان او ما تبقى
ليوم في شهر رمضان وهم يستعدون كذلك
للعيد هذا هو موقف المواصلات موقف
الحافلات الصغيره تقل المواطنين من من
مدينه مروي من السوق الى عده قرى مجاوره
هذا السوق يعني الحركه فيه بدت
بدات طبيعيه وفي طبعا لا يمكن ان نقول
البلد قد يتناسب المرارات الماضي وتحولت
فجاه الى
حياتها طبيعيه ولكن تدريجيا بدات المدينه
تعود وتسترجع انفاسها وتعود الى طبيعتها
شيئا فشيئا بشكل تدريجي الناس هنا لم
يتعودوا على اي شكل من اشكال التوترات
الامنيه خلال
تاريخهم في هذه المنطقه ما حدث من خلال
الايام الماضيه كان مفاجئا ومباغتا لهم
فيما يبدو ولكن
حاول الناس هنا تجاوز هذه
المرارات هذه الحاله الامنيه التي تعلقت
بمواجهات واشتباكات كان لها اثر بالغ على
كثير من السكان هنا وعلى كثير من الناس